hey friends its march second and we're
hours away from the launch of the
Nintendo switch this one's Rob's because
I don't have one of my own so don't tell
him that I have it and be sure to
subscribe and don't tell Rob thank you
here's some news
first up overwatch gets a new character
here's all the details on ERISA
following a series of teases Blizzard
has finally unveiled the newest addition
to / watches roster ERISA ERISA is a
tank class character whose gameplay is
engineered around protection her weapon
is the fusion driver an automatic cannon
that deals constant damage but slows her
movement speed the alternate fire is
halt which launches a charge that she
can detonate to slow enemies and pull
them toward the explosion her abilities
include fortify which reduces the damage
he takes to make her immune to action
impairing effects and protective barrier
a stationary barrier that can be
deployed to block enemy attacks her
ultimate is super charger which launches
a device that buffs damage done by any
teammates in its line of sight the
device itself can be destroyed by
enemies you can try out arisa now on the
PC versions public test realm a date for
her release in the live game has not
been announced but check out gameplay
over on gamespot com next up Bioware
cancelled Mass Effect Andromeda is
multiplayer beta here's why yesterday we
got news that Bioware had cancelled Mass
Effect Andromeda is multiplayer beta the
developer has now apologized for that
and explained why it was necessary quote
sorry we won't have a multiplayer
technical test producer Fernando Mello
said on Twitter I know many were looking
forward to it as were we long story but
right decision for how close we are to
going live he added Mass Effect
Andromeda multiplayer has had the most
extensive user testing we've ever done
Melo also mentioned that there was a
closed alpha for Andromeda earlier this
year that was held on retail consoles so
the game has been tested in the wild
people who attend PAX East this month in
Boston can play multiplayer mode
additionally EA origin access
subscribers can get a crack at the
entire game ahead of launched one
arrives for the subscription service on
large 16th finally mellow tees that by
we're still has more to announce about
Andromeda's multiplayer he kicked things
off with an image of the modes character
selection screen Andromeda's multiplayer
will tie into the game's campaign in
terms of gameplay you can expect to be
on the move more often than in Mass
Effect 3 whereas that game often saw
players often stay in a fixed location
they could defend Andromeda will throw
new enemy types at you that force you
into or out of cover full game launches
on March 21st
and finally and justice choose new
character is dr. fate who's totally not
dr. strange netherrealm studios today
revealed the latest addition to
injustice tues growing roster dr. fate
he's a series newcomer who's totally not
the same guy as marvel's dr. strange the
helmet clad sorcerer debuted way back in
nineteen forty and various incarnations
have existed in the DC Comics universe
since then dr. fate joins an already
diverse cast one that injustice to
designer John Edwards promises will be
the largest roster that we've ever done
according to Edwards fate brings
something totally new to that lineup he
said quote we look back and we were like
hey we don't have a predominant spell
casting magic based character dr. fate
being essentially the most powerful
magic user in the DC Universe seem like
just a real good fit Edwards provided
some insights into fates fighting style
during a recent preview event saying he
is one of the more complex characters
mechanically so he doesn't have any
straight physical text so his in close
combat is not as good as Batman
obviously or Black Canary he fits a
ranged play style for the most part he's
very strong at controlling space and
keeping the opponent away from him in
addition to that he uses traps injustice
to launches for ps4 and xbox one on May
16 be sure to join us for our Nintendo
switch livestream tomorrow we're gonna
play more zelda more one to switch it's
gonna be so much fun 11 a.m. pacific
time i'm going to play on rob's all day
long and not give it back to him join me
tomorrow thanks
you